völlig überraschende wendung olaf scholz
verpasst sich ein völlig neues image der
scholzomat macht diese woche plötzlich
ein auf feminist unser finanzminister
will vereinen die per satzung ein
geschlecht ganz ausschließen die
gemeinnützigkeit entziehen und damit
natürlich steuervorteile
das ist ja oft ungerecht bei uns ich
frage mich immer warum ist attac nicht
mehr gemeinnützig der waffenlobby für
einen deutschen gesellschaft für
wehrtechnik aber schon zur scholz idee
ja könnte man fragen haben wir denn
keine größeren probleme
man kann sich aber auch sehr wundern
über die hysterischen reaktionen sowie
friedemann weise ratschläge in die
fresse mit friedemann weise
olaf scholz will reinen männerverein die
gemeinnützigkeit aberkennen da war die
aufregung natürlich groß dabei sind gar
nicht alle männer vereine betroffen
allerdings gibt es brauchtumsvereine die
von schuld vorstoß nicht betroffen sind
etwa der katholische männerverein aus
zuffenhausen
denn der ist nicht gemeinnützig was der
katholische männerverein tuntenhausen
ist nicht gemeinnützig wieder was
gelernt hat also gar nichts mit scholz
vorschlag zu tun aber das ist ja das
typische die diskussion gehen immer
völlig am thema vorbei
hier ein besorgter mann auf welt.de ich
habe mich schon immer gefragt warum es
meist nur eine gemischte und eine frauen
sauna gibt und kein herren sauna ich
werde daher für gleichberechtigung wo es
eine damen sauna gibt witze auch eine
für herren hermann f mein tipp googeln
sie mal männer sauna oder kommen sie
einfach mal nach köln
aber zurück zum thema hauptsächlich geht
es um rein männliche schützenvereine
wovon es immer noch viele in deutschland
gibt den wird hier immer gleich
militarismus nachgesagt aber da mache
ich mir ehrlich gesagt keine sorgen
[Musik]
und da waren noch nüchtern nicht nur
schützenverein ist männersache auch
karnevalsverein und vorstellen etage und
satire sendung aber das ist ja tradition
es hat nichts mit gender aspekten zu tun
man sollte vereine und deren tun nicht
nach gender aspekten beurteilen
insbesondere wenn sich die
traditionsvereine handelt egal ob es ein
männergesangsverein ist oder eine
frauenselbsthilfegruppe da wird niemand
ausgegrenzt sondern da wird braucht um
gelebt
das ist brauchtum der mann singt mit
kumpels kein schöner land und die frau
sitzt in der selbsthilfegruppe häusliche
gewalt aber da sieht man's wieder sobald
es um gender geht drehen alle komplett
durch das fängt schon bei den kindern an
das gibt ärger der es zuerst gar nicht
die zukunft sein
erfahrungsgemäß wird alles besser wenn
die verschiedenen geschlechter
miteinander arbeiten außer der bundestag
der wer besser nur mit frauen wirklich
so sehr der bundestag aus wenn alle
männlichen abgeordneten mit männer
grippe im bett legen spd 29 prozent
endlich wieder geordnete verhältnisse
und falls sie sich fragen wo ist denn da
die afd
das ist ja das tolle die wären ohne
männer unter der fünf prozent hürde
was sagt ihr dazu afd wenn sie nicht
solche fragen und ideen für eine neue
politik verein sind sie denn ich finde
von welchem verein ich bin vom
katholischen männervereins tuntenhausen
tschüss
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hans de schreibt über die heute show ihr
seid die richtigen links [__]
besonders welke die stradivari unter den
arschgeigen bei euch smileys
freudentränen freudentränen
freudentränen freund rennkurs mit herz
vielen dank für ihr freundliches flugweg
für ein exklusives geigensolo von oliver
welke
abonnieren sie den kanal